Carmen Gonzalez we saw on c-span a while
back that you're calling for the
impeachment of Ronald Reagan now the
last time you were on our program few
years ago you were also calling for his
impeachment have things change or some
there are some new things that are
justifying your statements for
impeachment oh yes absolutely the first
time or the last time I was on this
program I made a statement that the
administration was the most corrupt
administration that in the years that I
had served under six different
presidents including Reagan this was the
most corrupt at that time that statement
was considered outlandish but I had
quite a bit of evidentiary material
covering almost every single major
Department since then it is now well
established that you have more than 110
high officials in the Reagan
administration that have been either
indicted or under indictment and that
does not include the characters that
you've seen in the recent so-called
contra iran-contra hearings so your your
present desire to impeach Reagan it
includes or is high no that was going to
be an impeachment resolution based on
the responsibilities as of the chief
administrator
however since so the more spectacular
cases the Department of Labor Secretary
who later apparently claimed exoneration
was being tried and had been indicted
and also the fact that while I was
preparing what we call this the
specifics
the southern more grave situation arose
which is the developments in this
irreversible course of the president of
intervention military intervention in
Central America and the present and
clear danger to the basic constitutional
structure of our former government as we
have lived under it now and the fact
that with his own admissions on national
television last November the 13th it was
quite apparent that he was admitting to
violations of not only treaties but
three of our basic laws and for the life
of me I haven't understood why his own
admissions at the time haven't really
been brought forth in a more direct
manner but nevertheless it took me some
four or five months before I had
prepared the impeachment resolution
based on those violations and admission
thereof by the President on March the
5th this last March the fifth and the
resolution has seven articles six
specific articles of impeachment and the
general article of impeachment that the
Constitution says is sufficient in
itself anyway
and the results of the introduction of
that resolution I've been simply amazing
to me throughout the country with no
real publicity given on in any other
major media they won't touch that no or
for that matter in the with the with the
exception of the first day on lots of
faith when I introduced it the speaker
had asked me to preside in order to
preside during the last remaining
special orders and when I finished that
two reporters came down and asked me to
go up to the press room because there
were some others who wanted to know if
indeed and in fact I had introduced that
resolution earlier that afternoon
and they did they placed a short story
in the wall under wires that day March
the fifth but how much coverage of God I
have no way of knowing but since then
and particularly within the last 60 days
it seems that in almost every state
there has been some reaction and some
concern expressed so I have received in
excess of six thousand five hundred
letters milligrams telegrams petitions
in three other states California
Washington Oregon I take it back for one
in New England there are organizations
that have been formed in order to
stimulate the dissemination of knowledge
of information concerning the
impeachment resolution known as House
Joint Resolution 1 1 111 what's been the
response in Congress you've been
ostracized no I haven't received any
criticism within the collegiate of the
membership I have had private remarks as
to the fact that I'm admired that I'm
considered one of those that's way ahead
of the events and and that were it not
for the fact that the ongoing hearings
by the Joint Committee which involves
the members of the Judiciary Committee
of the house that they would probably
consider it timely but that they feel
that it would be premature until this
joint committee has had a chance to
finish and complete its hearings
establish whatever must be referred to
the Justice Department on the basis of a
criminal culpability and I keep
reminding them that the impeachment has
nothing to do with criminal culpability
and of course so if you have not read a
little bit of the history as to why that
section is in the Constitution itself
I really do more than a cursory
examination or
of the particular portions the
Constitution it's easy to conclude that
a impeachment is like a criminal trial
when a matter of fact it isn't and the
fact that an impeachment or resolution
of impeachment which can be only voted
upon in the house is almost the
equivalent of an indictment or a recital
of allegations as to malfeasance
misfeasance and alike in public office
and all federal officials are subject to
impeachment and that only means a vote
as to whether they should go ahead with
whether trial in the Senate in the
settle but Reagan has said all along he
said I haven't heard a single word that
indicated any of the testimony that the
laws were broken well Jim Wright the
house speaker issued a statement of
seven laws that were broken
representative John Conyers said that he
said when you consider the evidence you
get a formidable list of law-breaking
duplicity and coverup and then Conyers
consider what went on to say that Reagan
Meese and Elliott Abrams are impeachable
so Conyers concluded said there is a
smoking cannon Reagan was not only
involved in the plan itself to sell arms
to Iran he was also involved in the
cover-up and he even gave false
testimony to the tower Commission now
there ought to be some people that when
you think I'm worried if the media
brought all these stories out that we're
reading dude it would be necessary to
impeach Reagan that these crimes are
much greater than anything rich poor old
Richard Nixon I think you feel sorry for
necks with you well speaking of the
tower Commission this was also brought
up by the nation there's a little story
in it since the tower came the tower
Commission went down in February it
finally closed down you know you can't
get a copy of that you can't get a copy
of the proceedings
what all happened there the nation and
an organization called the National
Security Archive went to the normal
through the normal channels to get
copies of this whole report and that
would be the White House office
administration and they said well we
don't have it so they started looking
around and come to find out Reagan the
Reagan administration sent it over to a
guy named Arthur called the house Jr who
is counsel to the president and his
office is not subject to the foi a the
Freedom of Information Act now the
National Security Archive went ahead and
asked them if they would go ahead and
make this material available to them in
culvahouse responded quote in light of
the ongoing criminal and congressional
investigations into the matters that
were the subject of the inquiry
conducted by the president's special
review board we do not believe it would
be appropriate to make discretionary
release of these documents at this time
it doesn't make much sense this thing
happened five or six months ago and it
was a committee composed of mostly
creampuffs I think Frank you mentioned
to me that three-quarters of the people
on the committee had actually voted for
contra funding all the way through so
they were predisposed to not find any
fault
well this was you know nothing much came
of the tower Commission and they still
don't want people to see this material
well the there's an article in the
progressive called gavel to grovel and
it talks it really lays it on the
Democrats for failing in their
responsibility to bring all these things
that we've been telling you about to the
forefront but of course they didn't and
not only do they not bring things out
like the secret team and the
drug-running and all like this but they
made sure that they just put the wimps
and the and the dummies and people who
were sympathetic to the Contras anyway
on this committee for instance they
didn't have Edward Kennedy on or John
Kerry or Christopher Dodd and they
certainly wouldn't didn't have on Henry
Gonzalez or Ron Dellums and of course
the media didn't put any of these people
on either oh they had Kerry on a little
bit but not very much and to make
matters worse the staff committees were
hopelessly biased in favor of the
Contras and covert action as we've
reported here from other sources
Thomas polgár who'd been CIA station
chief
in Vietnam was the one of the head
people coordinating the investigation
and Joey Lisk er another senator
investigate investigator had worked with
Oliver North before in helping to get
aid to the Contras and in the right-wing
newspaper the spotlight they talk about
why it was that the discussion on any
relationship with Israel was not gone
into with the with the element committee
and this was the talked about this and
there in the regular press I saw on CNN
I think it was the fact that they just
wouldn't Israel was off-limits well why
was this mark Lane and the spotlight
says that the pro-israel PACs gave more
cash to members of Congress than did all
other PACs and members of the Select
Committee in the iran-contra affair
received two hundred eighty thousand
dollars from pro-israel PACs and several
months ago Daniel Inouye and
representative Lee Hamilton had even
promised you stock Shamir that they
wouldn't subpoena any Israeli documents
on what happened and annoy had received
forty eight thousand eight hundred
twenty five dollars in Israel PAC money
so it's no wonder they left it alone now
the nation also covered that the Israeli
connection and they refer to a u.s.
Israeli joint initiative there was a
memorandum from oliver north to
Poindexter and it was heavily censored
in the tower Commission yes but yes but
but but and the but is what is but but
and the but is yes but but residual
front drop one in the shredded right
right right right my secretary
as I recall stack of logs and let me
help
and occasionally I'd drop one in the
shredder she then asked me I had I
thought I'd got it all that looks like
the Ayatollah toll of the ayatollahs
atoll is freedom from from freedom
fighter longer or words to that effect
well that they came out with a more
complete version of this after the tower
Commission it said that you chakra beam
who was Defense Minister of Israel
time offered a significant quantity of
captured Soviet bloc arms for use by the
Contras and a note another memo from
north to Poindexter said that Israel was
willing to put 2250 spanish-speaking
military trainers or advisors into
Central America it was an enticement on
my part that I had told the president
that little joke it wasn't some secret
ally north in the middle of the night
flying off on his own hoorah
then let the two sides sit down and do
kinetic the intestinal fortitude
vacation of bravery were murdered the
terrorists shortly thereafter murdered
ordered now the nation's story detailed
a couple other things that they didn't
uncover in their investigation
for instance that indication that North
solicited and received assistance from
general Noriega the head of the
Panamanian military in conducting
destabilizing operations within
nicaragua Noriega's offered to sponsored
political assassinations was turned down
but he did aid sabotage efforts within
Nicaragua the source said I didn't need
to know that you know one of the things
that disturbs me the political pundits
Mike and forgive me counsel what were
you asking me
not necessarily my father I didn't
create the Nicaraguan contra is no no
sir
no sir started shredding the Contra and
shredding dr. Hassan Bush shredding guns
treading government the United strutting
enterprises memory has been shredded now
another thing they didn't cover there
during the questioning of North he was
never asked about a hand-drawn chart
that was found in his safe one of the
things that he neglected to shred he had
shown in this chart the various kinds of
support that the Contras were getting a
lot of that was explained and was gone
over in the committee hearing but one
segment noting links between an
international youth committee and an
Institute for democracy still remains
mystery an aid to the to a member of the
iran-contra committee said this part of
the chart refers to a second network of
conservative foundations and tax-exempt
groups that North called on now this
isn't the one that we've talked about
before organized by
carl chanel and richard miller we've
talked about that extensively they said
that the committee investigators
believed it included a number of
prominent conservative groups but the
committee's didn't pursue it at all
another staffer said that they weren't
much interested in it because the
Democratic members who as we've said
we're a bunch of cream puffs didn't want
to look like they were attacking these
established conservative organizations
and one more thing no sir
no so sending guns sending guns sending
gun sending guns sending guns sending
guns
sending guns sending guns sending gun I
then picked up the phone I was left
holding the bag in fact I got two of the
grossest bad and the ugly the good and
the ugly grossest home banned brothers
that has a long reputation of European
potentate I think the government the
United States should have been out of
options
to make any serious serious serious
serious one Dickens of the time is a
difficult thing believe me gentlemen
it isn't as difficult for you as it is
for a guy that's got to come up here and
tell the trapar clean hosiery another
issue the September 5th issue of the
nation they bring up one other things
they didn't ask Ollie north while he was
up there he said why didn't the
congressional select committee members
allow lieutenant north to present why
did they allow North to present his
delusions as fact this is what they're
talking about he was testifying in March
1985 about the San Jose declaration
which was a document preaching the
virtues of democracy and was supposed to
have been written by the Contras in a
show of political unity they're getting
their stuff together they're going to
win the country etc now it says his
voice stick with emotion North likened
the statement to our own declaration of
independence in our own constitution he
says it was hammered out and compromise
and with differing views by men who all
sought a common purpose it was truly an
effort to arrive at amicable conclusion
to a bloody war well in fact the
Declaration was drafted by three men one
who was Oliver North and I did this in a
Miami hotel room north and contra
leaders although for Calero and Arturo
Cruz did this according to them as north
later wrote in a memorandum to McFarlane
that the objective was to convince the
US Congress that the opposition was led
by reasonable men members of the
committee's had that memorandum before
they ever questioned North but not one
of them pointed this out lo North was
out there up there singing the
star-spangled banner
instead the committee creampuffs watched
his old Ollie rapped as the American
flag around our contra hired gun the
whole thing is now stopped dead cold I'm
not trying to be flippant about that
undoubtedly everything that everything
else having gone wrong with this that
went wrong to some people really said
you know this guy really a sicko even
McFarlane said that North either ought
to be transferred or sent to the thighs
of naval hospital
Ollie North has been loyal to his wife
since the day he married her starting in
the spring of 1984 been doing that
little hanky-panky
I was already engaged and I asked her
when you put up things like the old
buffoon and you all snicker at it I
turned to others and you know that I've
got a beautiful secretary and the fact
is I went to my best friend and the good
Lord gave her the gift of beauty and I
asked her did I ever go to the Disney
World or a trip on the Space Shuttle oh
well I was about to leave for Tehran I
had already been told by director Casey
that I should be prepared to take my own
life because this kid won't be around
much longer as I'm sure you know I'll be
glad to meet Abu Nidal in equal terms
anywhere in the world up on the screen
for the whole world to see these things
kind of come in April's I guess I would
use my own money
Lieutenant Colonel Oliver North's
paycheck money went there to buy
leotards for our two little girls
we had an operational account and we
used the money for legitimate purposes
within that covert operation that think
there's a loose cannon on the gun deck
on deck on deck estate at the NSC that's
a cliff cliff cliff hanger of an ending
one of the really serious things is that
they didn't go into the drug-running
of the Contras and the CIA
even though information for months has
been accumulating about the CIA's
involvement in drug running and after
there were just a brief mention of it
which the committee poo-pooed and didn't
go into it all these kind of fluffed it
off the next day two days later a Senate
subcommittee actually heard testimony by
two CIA agents who were involved in
contra guns for drugs operations but the
iran-contra panel didn't go into it
Franco has some new drug information
we've of course given detailed accounts
on alternative views of the contra drug
operation but the covert action
information bulletin of summer 1987 has
quite a bit of new information on the
cocaine connection that I hadn't read
before this is the first time that I've
seen the top contra read leaders
implicated in this drug ring all of the
previous allegations touched middle and
lower level a chillon Contras who were
supposedly drug smuggling drugs as part
of the arms operation but Senator John
Kerry the Democrat of Massachusetts
testified in a congressional hearing on
to the alleged contra drug connection
that and I quote it is clear that there
is a networking of drug trafficking
through the Contras Kerry said at the
meeting and it goes right up to control
eaters Mario Calero Adolfo Calero and
Anne Ricci and Rica Bermudez who is the
military leader of the Contras so these
are the three highest cultural leaders
there's some other information about the
connection
- the Achara family which is the biggest
Colombian drug family that I hadn't
heard before and that comes from a US
citizen who was married to a Colombian
drug trafficker who became a witness for
the FBI and testified under the
pseudonym Wanda dough she was used as an
undercover agent and informant and Wanda
Doug testifies that on two different
occasions she witnessed the loading of
cocaine from the okay Choa family place
in Colombia on the CIA owned Airlines
and - on the flights that were
supervised by CIA agents that were being
used to fly drugs to the United States
and arms back to the Contras something
else interesting is that the log of the
copilot on the crashed plane that Eugene
hasenfus was on when his plane crashed
delivering arms to the Contras and was
shot down over Nicaragua the log of that
plane indicated that two previous visits
of the airline went to the barn killya
residents of the h OA drug family that's
more evidence that the CIA was involved
in this cocaine connection and it has a
lot more information about the Cuban
American operatives
in this many of who go back to the Bay
of Pigs
in fact the covert informaiton convert
action information bulletin indicates
that no fewer than 8% of the Cuban
Americans were evolved in the Bay of
Pigs invasion were later prosecuted for
a drug running that they became involved
in a drug business and were a large part
of the infrastructure of the illegal
arms operation and drug operation that
the Contras were running and it has more
testimony as
Senator John Kerry about the CIA
connection here that I hadn't read
before including a report by Kerry that
one federal drug operation that was
called off targeted the leader the
military leader of the Contras and rekey
Berta mez and Ed me said hey lay off of
this operation that the Drug Enforcement
agent so he wanted to carry through
because it involved the highest echelons
of the country leaders so this is a
quite a bit of new information that the
covert operation the covert action
information bulletin has brought out in
the drug connections the the nation also
in particular the August 29th issue of
the nation has a long story about the
drug connection another thing they add
to that is in fact one of the Contras
who was busted had returned to him
$36,000 that was impounded because he
told them that was designed for the
Contras and it also says that North knew
about this from early 1985 he received
several memorandums from his career
Robert Owen stating that some of the
Contra leaders are involved he said
they're questionable because of past
indiscretion involving drug running he
was telling this to North back in 1985
he named several Contras and has met his
memory was eventually charged by Costa
Rican authorities with drug offenses one
who another one has never been charged
and he continues to play a major role in
the White House arms network
I do I do shopping probably we all know
my sharpie I am riding her and I'm sharp
with cars and I don't shop for me cold
there's an awful lot and I do enjoy
shopping if kind of a hard way to help
when I get a little emotional about it
perhaps - a bloody bloody bloody bloody
war it is the most devastated Estela
copter in the world today and I am NOT
trying to impugn any defence contractors
but if we can get the model we ought to
build a building build a building we're
willing to give them anything necessary
to win officials well above my pay grade
to the hilt to fight prosthetic limb
immune ISM and tried to look after the
family owned off full-service campesino
director Casey said it was and I'm not
too sure that's a tional security
interest of the United States would be
severely jeopardized what do you mean by
damage to the president well when I
damaged the president can come in
several forms I do like to shop I'm
probably we all known for my shopping
and gym that made my blood boil I didn't
need to know that there was another
interesting from this Owen character he
sent another memo to Ollie north back in
1986 just before they okayed the hundred
million dollars for contra aid and this
is what it said that you may have heard
this before but I think it's worth
repeating he said quote I keep this is
true Ollie north from Robert Owen he
says I care and believe in the boys and
girls the men and women who are fighting
bleeding and dying but the reality is I
see it is there are a few of the
so-called leaders of the Contra movement
who really care about the boys in the
fields he emphasized this part this war
has become a business to many of them
there is still a belief that the Marines
are going to have to invade so let's get
set so we will automatically be the ones
put into power if 100 million dollars is
approved and things go on is they have
in these last five years it will be like
pouring money down
Cole let's talk about contra gate
certainly some people particularly the
media and a lot of the Congress people
and senators say well contra gate is
behind us it's things are worked out
shows the system is working and we
should put it behind us and go ahead and
continue in the future etc other people
say contra gate is an extremely
dangerous threat constitutional threat
Oh what's your opinion on this well
there's no question about it the nation
is undergoing one of the most serious if
not the most critical constitutional
crisis since the Civil War you have a
heedless president callously indifferent
to the Constitution and the limits
placed upon the executive branch by that
document he ignores the Congress he has
violated every single principle that
America basically stands for he has
ordered the assassination of foreign
leaders he doesn't like he has killed by
an executive decision that exceeds his
power under the Constitution up to now
it hasn't been exerted that way he has
killed and caused the kill innocent
children and women and civilians
he has invaded and suborn and attempted
to pervert the nationality the
sovereignty and nationality of
independent sovereign nations such as
those in Central America and elsewhere
in Latin America granadan he has
violated three of our solemn treaties
some of which we initiated ourselves he
violated not only three treaties but two
of our statutes with the invasion of
Grenada
he didn't consult Congress and for the
first time in our history even during
the Civil War the press was prohibited
from being anywhere near the invasion
even here in the Civil War you
the reporters covering the carnage and
for the first time the president was
acting as if he were a British official
or Prime Minister see we in America
don't realize what it means to have the
First Amendment if you will remember
some of the complaints by the hard
right-wing Hawks who never had any
children to send to Vietnam and could
abide the poor and the powerless being
killed with part a bit of indifference
actually saying that the press was
covering one side of the Vietnam
conflict we were just seeing the
atrocities of the American soldiers and
we were in covering the atrocities of
the Communists and that the press was
exceeding its a proper role and even
being anywhere around forgetting that
this is an undeclared war the press if
it is a free press cannot be bridled
under the First Amendment but in England
there is no First Amendment everybody
forgets that so if you will remember the
Falklands affair you read about the
sinking of the Essex and the death of
about 300 British sailors three days
after it happened because the minister
of information was controlling the
release of information you didn't have
any reporters anywhere near the scene
from England they're prohibited there's
no First Amendment in in England they
have their Official Secrets Act - and
they have the official secrecy I think
they want to say is a secret is secret
and that's it that's it but it goes a
lot further than Reagan though we talk
about constitutional crisis according to
the Christic Institute's information and
trial there
we have what they called a secret team
of people people from the Pentagon
people from the CIA inside the CIA
outside the CIA sometimes both working
with sometimes civilians businessman etc
they have been carrying on
assassinations illegal arms trades and
actually dealing with drugs you know for
decades there's no question long before
Reagan well what what is it you know
about this and this Congress are is
Congress aware of well there's no
problem there's no question that the
problem has been very basic since so
every war brings evils that are inimical
to the democratic processes if you will
remember after World War one you had the
Attorney General's raids the Palmer
Raids and you had the anarchists that
were supposed to be loose and you had
celebrated trials and he attempted to
port people like Emma Goldman and the
like and there was just a period of
hysteria and there was no question that
some of the laws that had been our
powers that had been delegated to the
president mostly the Espionage Act of
1917 and many of which were not recalled
to the Congress after they had been
constitutionally delegated to the
President and one of those powers has
enabled presidents in times of what they
define as emergency or perils clear and
imminent to the security of the nation
to invoke everything from
arrests to imposing embargoes presidents
don't have any power other than night
which in this case the Congress has
delegated and going back to the
Espionage Act of 1917 so that when you
have a declared war by the Congress all
of these laws come into play if a war
had been declared during the Korean
incident the Vietnam War
none of the demonstrators that
demonstrated would have been released at
any time they'd have been jailed
immediately and kept in jail as aiding
and abetting the cause of the enemy but
we're living in these twilight areas in
which these things have not been defined
the American people haven't defined them
to lose their elective officials and the
policymaking body known as a congress so
that when you have a president such the
thing that makes it more difficult and
dangerous is that in the person of a
pleasant smiling agreeable popular
almost charismatic individual like
reagan you have a very dangerous
situation because the powerful men who
surround him and are actually making the
judgments and the decisions are are
shaping whatever it is that leads to an
action i won't call it a policy because
there is no such thing whereas in a case
of say richard nixon even his strongest
supporters had some misgivings about it
and he was his character was such as
personality was such that there was a
residual fear in distrust in the case of
mr. Reagan since these are faceless
powerful individuals coming from the
most powerful corporate
and chill as well as corporate
structures in the world you have a very
different and dangerous situation it is
men like J Peter grace who are defining
who's a communist threat in Central
America because it's he the billionaire
that owns the the conglomerate that now
owns the old United Fruit now known as
standard brands that literally has owned
and continues to own Honduras which were
occupied so that when you have that
dangerous wedding of the unelected
nameless faceless shadowy figures but
nevertheless powerful enough to dictate
the actions the nation is facing one of
the most serious constitutional crisis
because there's no accountability the
there are on gate Watergate and the tire
commission before it it's very
disturbing because as a tire commission
very eloquently brought up I was
surprised that did even go that far you
have a country rudderless with a leader
who doesn't even know what's going on in
the basement of his home you were saying
a while ago that Reagan is really
controlled or the reins of the system
are really controlled by higher
corporate officials than all does this
mean that this renegade secret team is
really doing the bidding of the people
higher up in the American power
structure then whether they're doing the
bidding or whether they're doing what
they think pleases what they feel is the
power that be is something that you can
debate when I say that Reagan isn't
really I said this from the very
beginning that Reagan was in line to the
country he was saying look I've been an
actor and I'm asking you to elect me to
act the role of the presidency and he
has I said what disturbs me is that
Reagan has always been an actor that
requires a three by five cue card
in other words he needs scriptwriters
and it's the script writers that worry
me because I saw the names I had been
chairman of the ad hoc committee on the
Robinson Patman act the Magna Carter of
the little businessman in the Nixon
administration that was trying to kill
it we had extensive hearings or a period
in a year and a half men like Baker nice
Clark
all of those appeared they were all
involved one way or the other with the
Justice Department or the Nixon
administration are the private business
entities Arthur killed which they have
literally killed by now the
robinson-patman Act so when I saw these
names as the coterie surrounding or the
little oligarchic group surrounding a
President Reagan now there's no question
I don't think anybody debates that
Reagan is shallow intellectually any man
it's dangerous for America at a time
when the world has shrunk where the
world is totally different Latin America
Southeast Asia and other parts of the
world Europe is no longer the Europe it
was upon which our defense policies and
our 315 billion dollar defense budget is
predicated and that's the 1947 Europe
yet Reagan's mindset is a 1947 Europe
Latin America in 1982 he went to for the
South American countries in one he said
well I'm glad to be here and he
mentioned another country had visited
yet yeah when he returned to California
Ray medially after that trip his first
remark was my golly I didn't know those
countries were that different America
can't afford to hear that kind of
leadership in its most critical period
of development in a world that has
shrunk and it's it's fatal and it's it's
costing us and will continue to cost us
much in both Treasury as
blood last week we looked extensively at
the constitutional crisis says
congressman Ghazali saw it summarized
here although there's no question about
it the nation is undergoing one of the
most serious if not the most critical
constitutional crisis since the Civil
War you have a heedless president
callously indifferent to the
Constitution and the limits placed upon
the executive branch by that document he
ignores the Congress he has violated
every single principle that America
basically stands for he has ordered the
assassination of foreign leaders he
doesn't like he has killed by an
executive decision that exceeds his
power under the Constitution up to now
it hasn't been exerted that way he has
killed and caused the kill innocent
children and women and civilians
he has invaded and suborn and attempted
to pervert the nationality the
sovereignty and nationality of
independent sovereign nations such as
those in Central America and elsewhere
in Latin America granadan he has
violated three of our solemn treaties
some of which we initiated ourselves he
violated not only three treaties but two
of our statutes with the invasion of
Grenada University of Texas history
professor Tom Philpott will look at the
situation from two aspects first the
Constitution what does it say
is it being violated and secondly he
refused the history of repressive
legislation and we compare that with
what is happening today but first let's
look at the latest in the series of
repressive legislation FEMA perhaps the
most dangerous of all the aspects that
the government didn't go into is the Rex
84 executive order which we reported on
from
the spotlight back in 1984 and it was
about the plans which Oliver North was
helping to gin up in relationship with
the Federal Emergency Management Agency
to have that agency actually plan and
take over the government a coup if you
will in case of war or national
emergency or in case that the Reagan
wanted to invade Nicaragua and there was
a lot of dissent in the country over
this the spotlight has a eight page
special on the whole aspect of this and
it says that what FEMA has done is to
set up a parallel government and all
these people are trained and people at
the state and local levels are trained
also and particularly the police
organizations but people were trained so
that when the president gives the word
and of course all he has to do is give
the word that he doesn't have to get
congressional approval he says it's a
national emergency then they have things
set up so that they actually go in and
they will run the various departments in
the executive branch a little bit the
military to do this I have some
information on this Frank that was
published in in these times that somehow
got hold of the Department of Defense
directive that was put out by this
Federal Emergency Management Agency FEMA
that Oliver North helped to write up in
the Pentagon document states in those
areas in which martial law has been
proclaimed military resources may be
used for local law enforcement normally
a state of martial law will be
proclaimed by the president however in
the absence of such action by the
president a senior military commander
may impose martial law in an area of his
command where there has been a complete
breakdown in the exercise of government
functions by local civilian authorities
military assumption of judicial law
enforcement and administrative functions
of local government will be based on
necessity it is actual and president and
the performance of these functions will
continue
only is so long as necessity of that
extreme nature requires interim military
intervention if there was a nuclear war
or if there was a an invasion of Central
America and there was protests by the
people against that a national emergency
could be proclaimed and this FEMA Act
would make it possible for the military
to take over local government to take
over the courts to take over the media
to set up concentration camps for all of
the protesters against the current
government policy and to in fact have
ineffective martial law in the country
this the author of this directive was
Frank Carlucci who is now Reagan's a
national security adviser and of course
Oliver North and in these times points
out that Reagan has long had a
fascination with martial law as the
Governor of California from 1968 the
1972 Reagan ran a series of martial law
domestic war games under the codename
operation cable splicer in which the
California National Guard carried out
mock operations of taking over the
country in the case of a breakdown of
law and order the man in charge of these
National Guard wargames was Colonel
Lewis jube Rita Jo Frida who Reagan then
named the head of this federal emergency
management our German our shal law
programs
Alexander Coburn in
in these Times reports that gene Ephrata
attended the Army War College in 1970
and there wrote a paper advocating
martial law in the case of a uprising by
black militants along with roundup and
transfer to assembly centers of
relocation camps at least 21 million
American Negroes this paper was the
basis for part of this FEMA program of
the Reagan administration so this is
about as close to a sort of fascistic
martial law concentration camp set up as
you could possibly run and this is again
during part of the hidden secret policy
of the Reagan administration since 1981
they were working on these well this
should be noted that all this actually
started under Carter he's the one who
set up the FEMA the Federal Emergency
Management Agency and at that time they
were under any type of emergency they
were they would be able to arrange for
the succession to office an emergency
organization of departments in agencies
in other words they determine who would
be running the the government they would
determine which governments both which
people both in and out of government
would have the access to shelters in the
case of war and so you got to have a
buddy of FEMA if you want to live and
they would also coordinate the federal
activities concerning international
civil emergency planning
well of course under Reagan this became
much more sinister and like you say all
this training which they had done in
California but there's another sinister
aspect of this - sounds like the Soviet
Union the Department of Health and Human
Services would set up mental health
centers where citizens considered
deranged or overly upset might be
confined at the pleasure of the
president yeah but what this is is the
spotlight goes on and say they're
actually people who are trained so that
they can move in and
and take over the Sabine's well as in
using the military so they can actually
have a complete coup and Tom how does
this bear on the iran-contra scandals to
what extent is this a constitutional
crisis that the Constitution was
actually subverted in these events well
first I do think the Constitution was
subverted and secondly the US Congress
in trying to pose that seemed to me to
be afraid to pose it directly in the
hearing in the hearings and even
elsewhere they seem to be willing at
least for the indefinite future to
submit to the popular attitude that the
Congress is the most minor entity of our
government or at least it's no better
than second and the presidency has
primacy the congressman seemed to be
apologizing all the time to me during
the hearings and when they talked to the
press outside the hearings they seem to
be very apologetic they didn't ever
assert it seemed to me the place of the
Congress in foreign policy in the making
of the laws of the United States and the
oversight of the execution of the laws
of the United States they seemed timid
and how does the Constitution constitute
the relationship between the presidency
and the Congress
the Congress has the power quote to
regulate commerce with foreign nations
to define and punish piracies and
felonies committed on the high seas and
offenses against the law of nations the
Congress was merely consulted after the
fact about the adventure in the Persian
Gulf but that language doesn't suggest
that that is the the priority of action
the power has the sole power the
Congress has the sole power to declare
war to raise and support armies and
that's in the plural as if there won't
be one standing army and that was the
intent at the time that there should be
occasional armies called upon when
needed and Congress cannon at
appropriate monies for them for more
than two years at a time
again the bias was against the standing
military the Congress has the power to
provide and maintain the Navy the
Congress has the power to make rules for
the government and regulation of the
land and naval forces of the United
States to provide for argument
organizing army and organizing the army
and disciplinary in disciplining the
militia and governing all such parts of
the militia as are called into direct
service to the United States and so on
the president in the realm of foreign
policy is given an article two of the
Constitution the right to make treaties
and then the language is by and with the
advice and consent of two-thirds of the
Senate present well this is very
interesting in relation to the
iran-contra affair because obviously
Reagan himself the presidency was
selling arms to the Iranians without
even consulting without even telling the
Congress what he was doing whereas the
Constitution says it's up to the
Congress to carry out commerce with
foreign nations which obviously this oh
and there's much much more they were
raising armies and exactly everything
and then the Contra thing the Reagan
administration was raising and funding
its own army ie the Contra and lying to
Congress line to Congress even when
Congress banned all support military
support to the Contras
why are they giving it to them the
excuse of North in particular was that
he was trying to it was hurt his word
circumvent the Boland Amendment which
prohibited aid by intelligence-gathering
agencies to the Contras desert convent
it without breaking it then there was an
argument how do you circumvent without
breaking and he said but not to
circumvent the constitution and then he
interpreted the Constitution is giving
the president supremacy in Foreign
Relations that's a misinterpretation it
is and furthermore I think it's to me
it's chastening arresting encouraging to
look at the Constitution and see then in
article two that the last two
stipulations about the president's power
are first he may be impeached and anyone
that he directs to break the laws of the
United States may be impeached and
lastly his chief duty is to take the
care to see that the laws are faithfully
executed well that's the spirit of the
Constitution at the rigid construction
revenge time you mentioned that one of
the last two stipulations was that the
president could be impeached and do you
think that the the actions committed by
the Reagan administration would
constitute grounds for impeachment Henry
V Gonzales of course as argued that it
should
I think strictly speaking is proceeding
congressmen ginza Gonzales is correct
but it also impresses me that there are
so many people in the executive branch
and in the Congress and in the judicial
branch who seem to be in doubt as to the
meaning of the Constitution or who
seemed equally indifferent to the
niceties of the Constitution that we
have a far deeper problem here than can
be settled by trying to impeach one or a
few officials including Reagan Reagan is
not guilty of thinking things
many people in the government in more
than one branch think and that is a
problem what now guilt I said that Regan
is not guilty of thinking things that
many people in the executive branch many
people in the Congress many people in
schools of law also think that the kana
the president is superior to the lies
and therefore has the right to carry out
some activities without consulting I
think that attitudes about our
government have gone parallel somewhat
to the advances of big business in the
United States in the 20th century the
American people are management minded
people they take it for granted even if
they don't like it so much that
management is powerful and everyone else
is in the posture of some sort of an
employee and then we need a strong
manager that's what's the only way
things are they're afraid that their
weakened the sort of system of the
presidency by impeaching the second
president after Nixon in the last what
15 years or so well Tom we have a
situation today where we don't declare
war and we particularly under Reagan
they have elevated to doctrine to policy
low intensity warfare where they will
carry on wars estimated by the CIA
Watchers but to many as 50 around the
world right now where and all this
undeclared just done out of the hip
pocket kind of of the presidency and the
CIA and yet we have in the Bricker
amendment after world war ii and the
Ludlow amendment you were talking about
after World War one in which they were
trying to go the other way and restrict
the ability to the Ludlow amendment was
was a deep reaction to the horror story
that was World War one and when was that
what year was that it was advanced in
1934 35 36 37 and it failed in 1937 but
it had the support of 75 73 percent of
people polled by the Gallup Organization
the the Ludlow amendment wanted to make
it impossible for the Congress to
declare war except in case of invasion
unless there were a national referendum
in which the majority of the American
people said we support war it had a lot
of support the Republican Party was very
heavily for it the Democratic Party was
split it might have passed it would be
so different if it had well it didn't
and I'm not advocating that it should
have but it showed a spirit in a mood
whereas serious Congress certainly must
declare it but Congress shouldn't
declare it without really consulting the
people of the United States the Bricker
amendment in 1953 was the result of
particularly Republican animosity toward
the peace making of President Roosevelt
and then President Truman visa vide the
Russians at the end of World War two and
what it would have stipulated was that
not only could the president not enact a
treaty without the advice and consent of
the Senate he could make no agreement
without the advice and consent of the
Senate
no foreign agreement of any kind without
the advice and consent of the Senate
President Eisenhower when he accepted
the nomination the Republicans in 1952
said I opposed the Bricker Bricker
amendment and I will actively oppose it
and he did and it failed one year later
he wrote his letter to z 'm in vietnam
and that is the basis supposedly for our
commitment to go to the age of the South
Vietnamese up one piece of paper that
President Eisenhower wrote in 1954 very
fateful piece of paper I've seen some
people who talk about this subject they
say well Congress willingly gave away
their powers to the executive branch
when it passed the National Security Act
it has set up the CIA that
it gave more powers to the executive
branch to carry out foreign policy and
war and also set up the National
Security Council and what year is this
right this is what 47 was that no it
wasn't until 1950 Oh 50 or kaftan the
spirit of that act or would seem to be
the spirit of the act was not was not
consistent with the overreaching
worldwide clandestine activities of the
government that we're learning about
right now it was to create a a
counterpart to the old Office of
Strategic Services which was created
during World War two in the heat of war
to have a counterpart to that in time of
extreme tension which the United States
was in with the Soviet Union it was a
very limited agency at the start and it
was primarily not an action agency and
the National Security Council was a
safeguard the notion of the NSC was that
it would safeguard the president and
vital decisions one of the first
decisions they made was whether or not
to build a hydrogen bomb the idea was
that simply using the cabinet to make
decisions like that or not even using
the cabinet as Roosevelt had proceeded
with building the atomic bomb was too
serious it was in keeping with the
notion that these things should be
accountable these things should be on
the record instead of having a
clandestine group a shadow group making
these decisions there should be a group
with responsibility for the decisions
well I think we've advanced in a very
strange way since then
the first National Security Council had
eight or nine members it grew in five
years to 20 members now it's nearly 400
members it's a bureaucracy and it's an
action agency that wasn't intended in
the last 40 years in the United States
the president has gained
more and more power at the expense of
the Congress yet for the Reagan
administration it wasn't enough power
the Reagan administration wanted more
power for the presidency less for the
Congress to used the National Security
Agency as a arm of presidential power to
carry out certain actions that would be
outside of the scrutiny of the congress
of the public that would simply be a
power arm as it were of the executive
and apparently more than apparently
patently the Reagan administration has
distorted the way the cabinet positions
are supposed to be used the Secretary of
State the Secretary of Defense do not
have the standing that they once did
other presidents have had difficulties
with secretary Secretary's John Kennedy
with Dean Rusk President Roosevelt with
Cordell Hull and relied on advisers but
those advisers were known to other
people interacted with other people
reported continuously to the president
and acted at his direction nothing like
what is supposed to be the case that the
NSC kept the president in the dark and
ran its own policy will return with
Professor Tom Philpott later and he'll
give us a rundown of the history of
repressive legislation in the United
States but first let's hear what
congressman Henry Gonzalez says about
the situation these preparations for an
actual military coup in conjunction with
the Federal Emergency Management Agency
originally called Rex 84 where they were
preparing concentration camps those in
addition to the ones authorized by the
McCarran act veteran in the 50s where
they could put the people in
concentration camps that were on the FBI
list that's right but Oliver North was
involved with FEMA in doing some
planning yes now what what what do you
know about this well it transcends north
of course if you'll remember it was my
colleague from Texas Jack Brooks that
was pursuing that line of questioning
with mister
north and he was stopped by chairman
annoy two times and chairman and Nagi I
don't think has a legal background so
that the proceedings again as in the
case of impeachment were in the popular
mind given the same relevance as if it
had been a court proceeding in which
Colonel North was answering charges but
the truth is that it was simply a
congressional Commission of Inquiry our
Committee of Inquiry and the Congress
under the Constitution is limited in its
ability to investigate it's not an
executive branch it's not a CIA it's not
an FBI and it can do so only for the
purposes of perfecting legislation so
that unless you have a sharp chairman
you can have an agile witness helped by
an agile lawyer make it look as if
they're winning a adversary proceeding
as if it were in a criminal court which
it never has been and ever is however
what isn't very much publicized is that
both North Poindexter's and the others
are facing grand jury investigations and
possible indictments in a criminal case
that is that is a court of proper
jurisprudence and you don't have the
publicity you don't have the same thing
you do in the committee hearings but
nevertheless is indicative of the
gravity of the activities of north now
with respect to Brooks challenging north
are asking him about these residual
standby plans which have been in
existence for some time but which are
more proximate to us today as a result
of a national security advisory that
President Reagan signed in May of 1984
and which of course is by its very
nature under the coverage of
from security and you could be hauled up
and brought in by the FBI and charged
with espionage if you were to reveal any
knowledge as to the exact content of
that document because it's under the
restriction of security and secrecy this
is a reason why you saw that sudden
flurry of spies including the grandson
of the historian Eliot Morrison it was
in September and October of 84 that
followed the signing of this national
advisory security order of the president
in May because it changed the area which
up to then was permissible for the
release of information but after that is
not and that executive order or rather
that the national security advisory is
one of those but there's no question
that it was patterned after what was
talked about you're in the Watergate
crisis at that time there were standby
powers general Haig at that time was the
one in which there were such things
seriously discussed as the suspension of
the national elections in 1974 are
rather 72 72 if there were turbulent and
disorder throughout the country that
would prevent an orderly process well
who's going to determine that once you
do that then it's possible to invoke
such things as military it's the same
thing in the basic legislation
establishing the Department of Energy
were you aware of the fact that under
that the Secretary of Defense could call
in the troops that is a Department of
Energy the Secretary of Energy could
summon the troops with respect to
Tomic security or atomic plant security
and these are things that have yet to be
fully evaluated there they haven't been
debated so they haven't been evaluated
and it is true that when you have the
option left to a sec you t'v to
determine when that period of dangerous
the word today's terrorism one reason
the i ns was rounding up the sanctuary
people in churches in arizona you know
we have seven priests ministers and lay
workers in our Penitentiary's now we're
doing no more than trying to help the
Salvadoran refugee but I ns raised the
issue in the specter and the
administration that the possibility was
strong that some of those so-called
illegals were covert terrorists the way
it is a dangerous times we live in our
system is brittle we're celebrating the
200th anniversary of the writing of the
Constitution there's nothing there's no
divine sanction that says that we are
going to enjoy this form that we take
for granted until the 200th anniversary
of its initiation that is it won't be
until March 3rd 1989 that we can say we
have reached a 200th anniversary under
this form of government under this
constitution do you find it disturbing
that people like the Attorney General of
the United States and the President of
the United States and some of the
judiciary say that we really don't need
the amendments to the Constitution
particularly the Bill of Rights all we
need is the basic Constitution which the
framers and secrecy in Philadelphia said
that we should have this is the rage and
controversy surrounding the personality
of the individual judge Bork that
President Reagan has submitted for
appointment to the Supreme Court
that's exactly what he has reflected in
his ideological judgments and decisions
and writings and lectures and the like
and it's a it is as if they are saying
everything that has happened since
Justice Marshall John Marshall in the
1830s made the fundamental decisions
regarding the supremacy of
constitutional interpretation by the
courts as if we should go to the prior
period to the status quo ante and
because a Bork is saying and I'm sure
that the Attorney General who is less
intellectually capable is more crudely
saying to the strict constitutional
interpretation well if you go to that
you'd go back to the pier at a time when
slavery slavery was recognized in the
Constitution and the divine right of
private property so that we're talking
about
edia logs which is the basic cause of
the troubles we find ourselves because
for the first time in our history we
have as president and ideologue we
haven't had before there's another
aspect or a couple of aspects this total
framer that we're talking about these
activities as a secret team type of
activity it came out a few weeks ago a
few days ago in the socialist newspaper
in these times and also in the nation
talking about the October Surprise group
gift which was part of Reagan's when he
was running for the presidency the first
time against Carter and we find these
same people popping up their C chord and
you tell us the belly was more insidious
than that it's the first time since well
even then we couldn't say that there was
an insidious invasion of our inner
executive branch workings but you're in
the Mexican War there were a couple of
battles needlessly fought because some
of the generals like Taylor and Scott
were wanting to get elected president
the battle of Buenavista was absolutely
unnecessary but Taylor wanted to be
President and but since then we haven't
seen the invasion of what is supposed to
be the controlling civilian portion of
our government by the military as we
have lately and during the 1980 election
it was clearly evident that you had very
serious professional violations by such
as the head of the Strategic Air Command
who bitterly de tested Carter his
commander in chief he bitterly detested
him and actually was in communication
not only was Reagan but with his
campaign campaign directors advising
them on how they could injure President
Carter in that election of course it is
it is very disturbing to know that when
that aborted rescue those helicopters
crashing that it was general Secord who
was in command of the coordinating
coordination which in retrospect the
military said was faulty and Colonel
North our same Ally was standing there
on the border of Iran and Turkey
observing the operation from what I
understand what these articles are said
is that the people who were pushing
Reagan for the presidency against Carter
had made a secret deal with the Iranian
government promising them arms later if
Reagan were elected in return they would
not release the hostages during while
Carter was still president and so
amazing the hostages were released right
after Reagan became president and yes
started getting their arms as a matter
of fact they were released on the very
day that President Carter was turning
over the presidency to Ronald Reagan and
that was January the 20th 1981 that
always smelled a little bit to me I
thought what a coincidence there is
evidence there is no question there's
incontrovertible evidence that the
shipments to Iran through Israel began
at that time and coincided with these
intermediaries that all of a sudden
appear as big fact totems in these sort
of unaccountable operations for which
the president says he has no
responsibility even though these are the
men that he surrounded himself with
there's only one thing I hold a
modern-day president fully 100%
responsible for and that is the
decisions he alone makes with whom he
surrounds himself in other areas it's
possible to say that the president can
decree a certain thing and it may be
down the line it's not going to be
carried out as he visualizes it but in
this area note and this is a reason I
was very distressed even during the
campaign in 1980 and predicted you're in
that campaign that if President Reagan
were elected our children would be
fighting in the jungles of Central
America and Latin America and we've been
seeing lately
well I've been hearing little drip sand
dabs and dribbles about it over
past several months but finally starting
to come out that yes Americans Special
Forces of the US Army and people from
the CIA actually have been in combat in
El Salvador oh yeah in Nicaragua I
reported that you I reported that four
years ago four and a half years ago
uh-huh
why isn't this information like what
we've been talking about now why doesn't
it get out why didn't the media why
didn't the media ever have you on well
uh I don't know you know I haven't I
don't have any control over but last
October when that airplane belonging to
the Southern Airlines crashed at Kelly
and I was called in as I said that's
part of a CIA operation the Kelly Air
Force Base here in San Antonio
that's right okay and I was denounced
the very next day that's very you know
how long does it take for an editorial
to appear concerning some matter that
happened just 24 hours before one of the
local newspapers the San Antonio Light
had an editorial saying put up or shut
up how can you document the fact that
this was CIA operation so it so happened
that the thing that saved me was that
that the very day it came out was a day
that hasenfus this airplane was revealed
to have crashed and it was a Southern
Airlines it was a same airline that was
performing a contract directed by the
CIA so that I was amazed when my office
was inundated in fact the reporters
television radio even reporters from
other countries from China to Britain to
France were in there they didn't fit in
my office saying are you saying that
this is CIA operation and I said well I
don't know what all the fuss is about
this has been in common knowledge for
some time and he said well you're the
first one that says so that holds a
public office and I said well I don't
why I think maybe the reason is that
this crash that happened over the
weekend was in my district and I have
known of it I have asked questions I
said to me that isn't the disturbing
thing the disturbing thing is that we in
the Congress and our presidents have
allowed the creation of a private air
force that over which the regular
Department of the Air Force has no
jurisdiction as to the air worthiness of
the crap the competence of the crew and
the civilian agency the FAA which is
supposed to have jurisdiction because
it's a private crap tells me they have
no ability to supervise and they're not
going to because all the CIA has to do
is pick up the phone and say buddies lay
off and so what you have is a very
dangerous situation in which private air
defense accountable nobody and to a
runaway agency that's not accountable to
anybody either
because the president even the director
of the CIA all over the past years when
you spoke about the incidence you had
read about himself is unaware of what
the office of security OS is doing that
is office of security for the CIA
these are the ones that were plotting
for instance together with the White
House special committee or office or
group that was organized in the autumn
of 1971 later became tabbed as a
plumbers because a young director they
brought in a young fellow by the name of
Bennett he was about 34 years old in the
Nixon administration that was plagued
with paranoia secretary Kissinger was
sure that everybody was leaking on him
so he didn't trust anybody except the
Naval Intelligence the chairman of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff Admiral Moore
didn't trust Kissinger called him a
secret agent of the Soviets
and Nixon became obsessed with the idea
that everything was being leaked out of
the White House so they formed this
group this guy Bennett then called in
and up shows one James McCord one II
Howard hunt one Garden Liddy and so
they're sitting there figure not how to
plug leaks and they said one of the
biggest leakers is Jack Anderson why did
you see the colony published the other
day he's Bona have gotten that through a
leak so then the where they met in the
executive building to figure out how
they were going to knock off not control
the leak but knock off Jack Anderson
killing absolutely
and so then Liddy says well I know
there's a doctor that's been working on
some things over at the CIA I think he's
retired but let's get him and and he has
ways I've learned about it so they call
this doctor when he found out what was
in their mind he got scared and he said
no what I can do though is give you some
chemicals that we've been developing you
know the psychedelic drugs and all of
that were developed by the CIA and he
said if you can find a way to have this
ingested by the man say you're half an
hour before he speaks at the National
Press Club by the middle of his speech
shall be a ruling idiot and he'll be
discredited and they said ah no gordon
leaders said that's too slow
he said now the CIA has ways I'll tell
you what oh let's find out if the CIA
can get us a profile or some
surveillance ten anybody tell us does
Jack Anderson jog over there in
Georgetown if so we ought to be able to
find a truck meaning a truck to knock
him off then the CIA now this is a thing
that I'm telling you has had me the most
disturbed this is when a lot of my
innocence as well as I think most
Americans was lost
the CIA detailed 12 agents one full
dozen to conduct round-the-clock
surveillance of Jack Anderson's home
from January
to April of 72 now that was illegal
because under the National Security Act
of 1947 the CIA is prohibited from such
activity
the CIA is prohibited from domestic
activity and yet that has been the case
because it's runaway
it's unaccountable and one what you
could say is a bureau like the Office of
Security when it became obsessed with
the idea that they had molds it was
terrible
they were bugging the director the
director of the day they were bugging
the director the CIA in the Washington
hotel you know some people say the CIA
is a renegade agency it's out of control
other people say it is definitely
controlled by the president no way other
people say well portions of the CIA are
out of control and renegade not even
controllable by the director that's what
I'm saying so that's that's what you
that's what I'm saying I'm saying that
such offices within the CIA structure as
the office of security has operated in
such a way that not only is a CIA
director totally ignorant its operating
to make sure that he doesn't know what's
going on now when you have that what do
you have so there's actually this
renegade element not only with the CIA
but although they're friends outside of
the CIA well it's all done which formed
this secret team as the Christa case but
it's all done in the name of patriotism
and protecting the security of the
nation just like Ally North he'd stand
on his head for his commander-in-chief
forgetting that that's the only thing
that makes us different from such
nations as Germany where that was during
the Nuremberg trial what all of the
defendants said well we were following
her orders he was our commander in chief
in America ally North doesn't take an
oath to
commander-in-chief that's right he takes
an oath to the Constitution and to
defend and protect it from all enemies
both domestic as well as foreign meaning
the president of necessary so that this
is the difference this is what makes us
up to now different and the
insidiousness that is being brought out
by these hearings is not whether this
guy's a charmer whether he was doing his
duty and the American people sensed
properly that he on his own couldn't
have done it a colonel of course not
everybody knows that but everybody
overlooked the most salient factor just
like they overlooked in 1972 the most
disturbing thing of all that we had the
CIA that had been accustomed to doing
this a Howard hunt
guard Liddy but he Howard hunt and James
McCord that's what they had been doing
all over the country from Chile to
Lumumba in the Congo and there are a lot
of people said the same outfit was
involved in the Kennedy Center if if a
human being is given a power for which
he doesn't render any accounting or for
which he thinks he's omnipotent you
can't have anything else happening but
what we're witnessing these seem to be
pretty serious things now you have a
historical perspective of what the
United States has done in civil war in
World War 1 World War two how does this
stack up with things have happening past
ah
it pales everything else it's beyond
everything also if we go back to what
American schoolchildren still hear about
as an unfortunate thing in American
history that was corrected you know and
so that everything is okay ever since
the third alien act of July 1798
provided that the President of the
United States in the event of a declared
war and then the war would have been
declared against France the president
then could arrest imprison and
aliens from the homeland of the country
with which the United States was making
war okay it had to be war were declared
and the abuse the disregard of the
rights of aliens only from the country
in belligerency and it was never invoked
nobody was touched by that action
because of a storm of protest
now Henry Gonzalez said that if there is
a formal declaration of law all of these
of of war that all of these acts like
the 1918 Sedition Act and the Espionage
Act of 1917 they would automatically
come back into effect I think he's an
error there were four major laws made
during World War one the two you
mentioned and then one called the
sabotage Act which made it a a work a
crime against the war interests of the
United States to stop working which is
to say to participate in the strike and
then there was a fourth final sweeping
alien Act which not just Germans but any
aliens could be put in jail if they were
suspect and chiefly suspect of anarchism
now I don't think those laws can be
reinforced with act was written but what
we have here is a record of a preparing
for war by preparing to make a kind of
war against our own people in the US
Constitution every alien has every
protection that we citizens have and
these law suspended that and those laws
have been held constitutional and as
famous stuff isn't just against aliens
it's against after anybody now if you go
down to the Smith Act of 1940 the alien
Registration Act no time of war all
right it's because of a situation in
which war may become likely any alien of
any nationality can be detained or
deported for any suspicious action to
the safety of the United States that's
that's getting more extreme
but at least the context is war is
likely now we have in in 1940 there was
not a politician in the United States
who when he thought of the word war in
connection with the United States did
not assume a congressional debate and a
vote to declare war now there isn't a
politician who who thinks that any such
debate is as plausible anymore that's a
great regrettable change the emergency
detention Act of 1950 which is part of
the so-called McCarran act absented the
condition of war altogether hmm it was
for an emergency to do to be declared by
the presidency those emergencies and
included declaration of war or invasion
or insurrection of the United States or
threat of insurrection in the United
States and then anybody alien are
naturalized could be incarcerated on
suspicion that that person would
conspire to commit and act so it's no
overt acts even and the president could
just declare the situation just on his
own yeah I have to get approval or
anything
yes the American president vetoed that
act and it passed over his veto it has
since been repealed in 1971 but for all
we know given the clandestine character
of so many operations its incorporated
into this present act for preparing for
an emergency well even with that there
was a study made in the early 70s after
the act was supposedly repealed and the
concentration camps which they've set up
were still in a caretaker status and
some of those were the ones prepared for
the Japanese a hundred and twenty
thousand Japanese Americans who were
incarcerated incarcerated during World
War two during World War one there were
severe measures the Espionage acts and
the Sedition Acts which didn't have
anything to do with espionage they'd do
with criticism of the US government
something that seems peculiar about this
female
act that I wonder if you could elucidate
the accounts that we've read of it it's
not clear whether Reagan actually signed
this and it went into law or not how can
you have secret executive orders that no
one really knows about that have signed
and then you know put aside somewhere
until they become relevant is this part
of the constitutional system are there
precedents for this no I don't think
it's been tested yet either I'm not a
word that it has these presidential
findings that we heard I first heard
about during the iran-contra hearings I
have the effect of executive orders but
they're not issued and they they were
spoken of as being consistent with prior
legislation I don't know the legislation
we recall that Adolf Hitler never
abrogated or suspended the Vai Mar
Constitution he ruled under it until
1945 but he had an emergency act voted
by the Reichstag in 1933 and he was able
to decree without any kind of hindrance
from that Constitution which was still
in effect and what this all sounds like
is a constitutional abrogation by the
presidency and it's conceivable that
with a Reagan court it could be tested
in the courts and approved